bien mais nous avons nationale et
quelques semaines le site de l'open de
france mais pas seulement la structure
qui accueillera déjà la ryder cup en
2018 l'équivalent de la coupe du monde
du golf pourrait également recevoir les
jeux olympiques de 2024 si le dossier
parisien et retenus sont des plus belles
compétitions et dans les cadres se voit
les haines et les jo les ventes
nationales seraient les premiers
parcours du vol du monde andres et
wallons drive lkp et les gens s'adonnent
d'émotion à la vie les joueurs
disputeront les parties sur le parcours
de l'albatros le 18 trous réputé comme
l'un des plus compliqués au monde a été
entièrement rénové entre 2015 et 2016
pour organiser la ryder cup
le comité olympique qui a déjà visité le
site à trois reprises s'est dit séduit
il n'y a pas d'autres sites comme ça au
monde faut se rappeler que plus que un
golf c'est un stade de golf ça irait qui
si tout a été pensé pour les joueurs oui
un parcours exceptionnel mais aussi pour
les spectateurs et donc on ne retrouve
pas un goal de city plat au monde donc
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
cette force qui est la nôtre de pouvoir
accueillir de grandes compétitions et
surtout avec un parcours exceptionnel
les gones nationale ça ce n'est pas en
inquiète car on a on a sur place des
lits à tous que c'est le lait périmé ses
coulisses et on a un hôtel on a un
parcours des top niveau et donc à non
plus à ce n'est pas ça ce n'est pas une
préoccupation
forts de leurs 24 open de france
organisé depuis l'ouverture du site en
1990 les dirigeants ont mis en avant
leur expérience des grandes compétitions
pour convaincre le cio la ryder cup 2018
permettra de se roder une nouvelle fois
aux événements internationaux à 6 ans
des jo les faits d'avoir la rai à quatre
sur un avantage pour n'importe quoi
devenir dans le futur
c'est comme elle à la plus grande
compétition de golf du monde
est on est on est très fier de recevoir
la ride et le cab n'a pas douté que ça
va être un vrai aussi il ne travaille
très dur pour ça le golf national
pourrait accueillir entre 35 et 40 mille
personnes sur le site pour les jeux
olympiques deux fois moins de
spectateurs que pour la ryder cup 2018